[Music]
he's the Syracuse basketball coach and a
big win last night Jim Boeheim as they
beat Duke at the buzzer and probably a
brilliantly designed play by coach
boeheim as they have the game-winning
three off the glass although Charles
Barkley said it was luck here's a coach
Boeheim coach how are you this morning
bank shots go in from the three-point
line it's a little lucky there's
absolutely dead dead true the good part
of it was we did get the ball to the
right guy and he went down pushed it
down he'd made a three at the buzzer to
tie the NC State game and it was really
hard shot from the corner and this game
he you know he got a good said there was
three guys out of it wasn't like they
just let him come down and shoot and
there's no question when you bank it in
it's it's luck so the first part was
skill good planning get the ball the our
best player get it down the court then
we got lucky it went in but also you
don't call a timeout there yeah in which
I loved I love that okay III got the
ball the best player on my team has the
ball makes something happen as opposed
to letting Duke set their defense did
you come close to calling a timeout with
20 maybe and that's what I did at
Georgia Tech and we now that I you know
with the results you'd always wanted to
change
we got a block call first one of the
game and if I let it go I think we would
have well I know we would have gotten a
good shot maybe wouldn't made it but we
would have gotten a good shot but well
20 seconds left
sometimes you want to set something up
but I wish I didn't yeah we didn't take
time out of your sentence he stayed we
pushed it down and made a play so you
know you just you never know but with
less than ten seconds we try to go and
get the best shot we can with their
point guard having the ball do you say
anything did you even say anything to
Coach K could you find him after the
fans
you know we're such good friends that
you know he's the only guy we couldn't
get in the line but he came over and we
had talked and we talked - between my
press conference and his and you know I
mean he it was a great game and you know
we did get a little lucky and but as I
told him I said we needed this one a
little bit more than you did yesterday
oh yeah he agreed with that there's no
question but they've got a tremendous
team they're starting to round into
shape you know they had so many changes
this year they're still not to where
there could be but I think they're
getting closer this came up yesterday
and give you an idea how slow the day
was you against coach K right now
one-on-one well he's had major surgeries
this year she could be no contest okay
let's say both knees come on okay that's
a forty years ago he was a good player a
good player but it's been a good matchup
there's been a good matchup I think I
could have got him but we want we want
our I know I can beat him on the golf
course well there did your wife tell you
my text her last night she was very
happy she thought you were upset with
her and after you did it such a great
favor coming here and doing our gal I
didn't want that to continue so if we
owe you one we will we will pay you back
someday but I'll tell you one thing
about you guys especially your show now
that trumps on all these I can't walk
you can't watch political anymore I mean
you just can't watch it so your rating
should so-so because of Donald Trump
you're now watching our show where's
before I have to watch your show which
is sometimes a circus but not always I
have a better season than you're having
that's just put it out like we're trying
to get back on track we do have a good
team it took us a while we have four
first year players and a sophomore
starting so it's taking a while
but I think we are a pretty good
basketball team now and we just have to
keep playing getting better and we'll
see what happens at the end of the year
there's a lot of pretty good teams out
there and and any one of them could make
a run the top 20 teams could make a run
for the national championship and the
teams right behind them could make a run
to get to the sweet 16 or Final Four
he said Jim Boeheim Syracuse head coach
improved to 17 and 12 with the win last
night over Duke how do you deal with
hecklers yeah you try to walk right
through right through it not to not to
even listen or acknowledge it it's hard
to do it's hard to do sometimes you know
but you just do you just kind of get
walking and you just don't look up the
best line I ever got I have to tell you
this I'm in Cincinnati and we win the
game and it's a tough game we went at
the end you know it was the year after I
got into the Hall of Fame and I'm
walking out and there was a big
Cincinnati guy standing there and he
says hey hey hey I'm you're in the Hall
of Fame but you know probably the worst
in them I did I looked I looked I said
thanks I mean if you're gonna be bad at
least be bad in the Hall of Fame he may
be right maybe what but if you're in
you're in
did you see the you probably didn't see
this but Pitino was ready to go after a
fan last night you're on edge and some
you know you try to just try to keep
walking but you know hey it's easy to
sit here in the morning and say you
should just keep walking yeah but when
you're right there in that moment and
the guy gets in your face and says
something you know it's it's human
nature sometimes you just you know you
just react to it you reacted to a column
written by Pete thamel recently you went
off on this I didn't come on I just said
I didn't go off I said there was
the only accurate part of that column my
name was okay you would like to but it
just was speculation about you know
knowing people that I'm gonna fight when
I retire and none of that's true I mean
it's just not true
and no nobody could have told him that
now he can have that opinion he made in
his mind but you can't then say gathered
from people near him because nobody near
me has ever heard me talk about that and
I haven't I think it's best for our
program to coach and just coach day to
day and I've been doing that for the
last ten years I mean I could have
retired ten years ago and it wouldn't
shock me but is your retirement edged in
stone I mean you're you know I don't
know what stone these days I really
don't you know there's a plan in place
and we're gonna see what happens and but
basically right now I mean I might be
done this year mmm-hmm you know I mean I
you just don't know you just have to
wait till the season's over and you know
it's like some days when you have a bad
week at your show you think about like
going fishing don't you or something
well let you know when I have that bad
week but I haven't had that my career
yet not a bad week oh really oh oh day
I've got a bad day okay well sometimes
even on a bad day you might think that
way but then again what would you do I
probably teach people how to shoot
around the country I'd help out the kids
is what I do coach I know you I'm not
sure how much help it would be but it
was I don't know I think earlier in the
aren't going to help your team a little
bit you can teach other people remember
that oh I know it's like could Tiger
Woods teach how to play golf he might
not be able to cheat or John McEnroe
teach how to play tennis I understand
that but I'm dedicating my life sort of
the mother Teresa of jump shots that I'm
just going to get back to the community
when I'm all done with this well
hopefully you'll last a long time and
you won't mess
sup any young kids coming up if you need
help coach I'm here but not for the
banquet okay Congrats on the win good
luck in the coming weeks here thank you
alright let's so Jim Boeheim
I text his wife last night and I it was
837 and I text her I said you're gonna
win I think it was nine nine minutes
nine and a half minutes to go I said
you're gonna win don't hear from game
ends don't hear from her go to bed wake
up this morning at 1:40 in the morning I
get the you should be a fortune teller
and then had all these emojis on it then
that was it then fritzy goes Bay Himes
in for 11:35 today I said what's a good
thing I said sent a text to her saying
you're gonna win this game maybe we
don't get the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]